We need to change the way we think
about the climate challenge.
Because things are different this time.
We need to stop thinking about it
just as a problem, which it obviously is,
and start thinking about it
as an opportunity
which will motivate us to solve it.
I'm a venture investor.
I invest in early stage companies
and technologies,
and I see tremendous opportunities
in solving climate change.
That said, we've been here before,
and it's different this time.
We can reduce net emissions to zero.
And that was not obvious
even just 10 years ago.
Why do I think it's different?
Because we have cheaper inputs,
we have better technologies.
We have better policies.
We have a better sense of urgency.
And most important of all,
we have even better people working on it.
I'm from Silicon Valley,
and you can laugh or shrug
if you think that the Valley
is more part of the problem
than part of the solution.
But consider this.
To succeed, if we want to succeed,
we have to act
at such a truly massive scale.
We need the best investors
and entrepreneurs on our team.
And it's a fact that some 15 years ago,
a bunch of us started working
on technologies and companies
that could help solve climate change.
And we had some successes,
in solar and in wind,
in electric vehicles and transportation.
But, accelerated
by the Great Recession of 2008,
climate tech, clean tech came to be seen
as a string of investment failures.
I don't think we failed.
We were a little bit early
and a little bit naive.
We didn't have all those building blocks.
Not enough of us knew
that solving climate change
was the greatest business opportunity
of our generation.
And we were a little bit naive.
We underestimated
how hard it was going to be
to disrupt entrenched
companies and industries
that did not want to change.
But now so many more people
are invested in solving it.
We have those building blocks, and we have
even more people working on it.
That's why I'm so optimistic and excited,
why it's different this time.
Let me detail a few.
First, we have cheaper inputs.
The biggest input in our economy
and the dominant cost is energy.
Until now, the dominant source of energy
is fossils: coal, oil, gas.
Climate change is caused
by burning fossil fuels.
But now, prompted
by incredible decline in cost,
solar and wind are
the cheapest forms of electricity,
most places on the planet.
Until recently, while we knew that fossils
were the source of the problem,
we had no alternatives.
Stopping fossils would have meant
stopping the economy.
Alternatives now exist.
Two, we have better technologies.
Consider lithium-ion batteries
and how they enabled
the electric vehicle revolution.
Those batteries are now being applied
towards other applications
and other opportunities.
We have better computers
and new ways of using them.
Machine learning
and artificial intelligence
applied to big data sets
enables us to explore
and develop new materials.
It enables us to reduce energy needs,
and it enables us to solve problems
in previously unimaginable ways,
some as simple as software that companies
use to optimize delivery routes.
We use less fuel to get stuff places.
The bioeconomy has CRISPR
and other gene editing tools.
Those can be used to help plants
like wheat, corn, rice, soy
grow with less inputs,
less water, less fertilizer.
Massive opportunities.
And we are in the early stages
of developing equipment
that can suck carbon dioxide
out of the air,
with the promise of one day
reversing some of the pollution
we've been pouring into our atmosphere
for the past 200 years.
Three.
We have and are developing
better materials.
The streets we walk on,
the buildings we work in,
they're made of concrete and steel.
Combined, those two contribute
over 15 percent of global emissions.
Now we can start making buildings
up to 20 stories or more high
without any steel or concrete.
There’s structures
made of laminated mass timber,
which actually sequesters carbon.
And at the same time,
we're developing ways
of making steel and concrete
without emissions.
Fourth.
Climate tech is now sexy,
elegant and chic.
Electric vehicles
were invented in the 1880s.
As recently as the 1990s, though,
they were clunky and ugly.
You couldn't go much more
than 50 miles on a single charge.
Now we have safe, affordable,
fun-to-drive, sexy electric vehicles.
I think in five years
we're going to be surprised,
we'll be shocked if people
want to buy a gasoline version.
Or consider solar panels.
Not too long ago,
many communities banned them
from being installed on their roofs
for fear that they would
uglify the neighborhood.
Now they look like roofs.
They're a status symbol.
You have to have them.
Other panels are used
to power not just homes
but companies and factories.
Messaging matters.
Fifth, there is so much more
money being directed
towards zero-emissions investments.
Solving these problems,
building these companies
takes hard-working entrepreneurs,
and it takes money.
Until not so long ago,
there weren't many people willing
to invest in the riskiest technologies.
Now we have dedicated pools of capital
focused across climate,
from early-stage
technologies and companies
to later-stage development
and massive utility scale projects
that require billions of dollars,
which actually encourages
more capital to come in
and is a [virtuous] cycle.
Each of these examples --
this is not an exhaustive list --
but each of these examples are real.
Real opportunities
that are in development.
We also have better policies.
Governments are making plans
that make them good partners
and customers for entrepreneurs.
We know so much more
about climate injustice.
We have real demand
from the public to solve it.
We have engineers
and scientists and investors
working around the planet
on these problems.
Put these things together
and a clear picture emerges,
a realistic pathway
towards a clean future for all.
These things have another characteristic.
They are combinatorial.
One accelerates the other.
One propels the next forward.
For instance, with cheap
green electricity,
we will soon have cheap green hydrogen.
Green hydrogen can be used
to power homes and factories.
It can be used to make fertilizer,
or it can be used
to make steel without emissions.
Tremendous opportunities.
We're developing
storage systems and batteries
that are the missing link
to make wind and solar
firm and dispatchable,
real alternatives to fossils.
And ...
mark my words,
the combination of EVs
and electric trains,
remote sensors and big data analytics,
it's going to revolutionize how we move
people and goods around the planet.
Of course, we still have a lot to do.
We have to develop the solutions we have,
and we have to develop and invent some
to solve some wickedly hard problems,
many of which I've mentioned already.
For instance, how do we grow
healthy food without emissions
while protecting and restoring nature?
How do we construct our buildings
and fly airplanes without emissions?
How do we recycle minerals
instead of mining for new?
And how do we make chemicals
without drilling for oil and gas?
How do we make steel without emissions
and concrete that absorbs
carbon dioxide at scale?
And how do we all,
especially big emitters
like multinational corporations,
track and report our emissions?
Because you cannot manage
what you don't measure.
We need good, reliable,
transparent carbon accounting.
Another massive opportunity:
developing carbon accounting
and reporting software.
Now, so many people understand
the urgency of the situation.
We understand that new and now
go hand in hand.
We can't sit around
waiting for a solution.
We need to get out
and develop the ones we have
while we invent the ones
we don't have yet.
And none of this happens
without passionate people,
and that's why I'm so excited,
so optimistic.
I see it everywhere,
from young people in the United States
who refuse to work for a company
that isn’t committed to a clean future,
to engineers in Africa
developing the infrastructure, the water
and the electricity that continent needs,
but doing so sustainably.
And this is also combinatorial.
Great people attract more great people,
which catalyzes more money,
brings in even more great people.
It's a virtuous cycle.
Having worked -- the key factor
in any effort, in any enterprise,
the key factor
in that success is the people.
And having worked in innovation
almost all my adult life,
I can honestly say that the people
I work with every day are,
you are, the solution.
We are different this time.
And that’s why it’s different this time.
And we will succeed.
Thank you.
(Applause)